theoretically you can get all the
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
you need from your grains and fruits and
vegetables although you have to eat six
cups of 15
different uh plant foods every day to
get enough vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids in other words 6 x 15 six
cups time 15 different plants that's 90
cups of fruits and vegetables a day I
mean even if you have the belly capacity
to do that you'd be in the bathroom
running through rolls of charm and
tissue all day from that much fruit
right now so it is theoretically
possible to get your vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids from um grains
fruits and vegetables but not really
practical and of course most people in
America they eat potato buds out of a
Betty Crocker box and I'm I'm coming
here from Idaho you know about potato
buds uh and they think they're getting a
vegetable I eat vegetables I had the
potato buds today then of course there's
Wonderbread remember uh back 50 years
ago when I was growing up on the farm we
didn't have TV and we had um we didn't
even have dryers that went round and
around to entertain ourselves so we
always listen to the radio things like
um with the Green Hornet and Captain
Midnight and inner sanctum and we'd make
jelly sandwiches listening to these
things with Wonderbread and I studied
that Wonderbread rapper I mean I could
tell you how many blue balloons there
was red yellow and so forth and on the
rapper it said helps build your body 12
ways and about 10 years later the FDA
made him change it to help build your
body eight ways now if you go into a
grocery store and study the Wonderbread
rapper it just says Wonderbread they
made him take it all off of there and
you wonder what's in it
so even though it's theoretically
possible to get all the vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids you need
from your food I still recommend to my
patients that you supplement with these
things uh you don't take a bag full of
dirt from the Texas oil field and throw
it in the crank case of your car tracker
and say well there's supposed to be oil
in
there but we do that for ourself when it
comes to food and vitamins and minerals
I just find that amazing now minerals
are a different story plants cannot
manufacture minerals and we need 60
essential minerals every day to prevent
disease and
death plants only have minerals in them
based on whatever minerals are in the
soil and that's why we're in trouble in
America because for the last 100 years
and I know I did on our farm and I'm I'm
assuming most people do on their Farm we
used a very simple fertilizer called NPK
because back then for 25 bucks an acre
it would give us the maximum yield in
terms of tons and bushels per acre and
nobody paid us a a cash incentive or
gave us a tax um incentive to um make
sure we had 60 minerals in the soil and
therefore in our food plants we were to
grow tons and bushels and we did a darn
good job at it and that's why we got
paid it only takes 5 to 10 years to
deplete the essential minerals out of
our soils and if you irrigate it goes
faster than that and for a hundred years
we've been using
NPK now one of the things I want you to
pick up if you haven't already done that
is a free summary when you leave tonight
is a free summary of US Senate document
264 US Senate document 264 says there's
no more nutritional minerals left in our
farm and Rain soils and as a result the
crops that are grown there are minerally
deficient and as a result of that the
animals and people who eat these
minerally deficient crops get mineral
deficiency diseases and the only way to
to prevent and cure them is with mineral
supplements now the scary thing to me
about US Senate document 264 is it was
written and published by the US Senate
in
1936 59 years ago this information was
known did anybody ever give it to you
before no and that's the time at which
in in agriculture we started putting
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
into animal feeds 19
36 in humans unfortunately for us we got
Wonder drugs this is when we got
penicillin sulfa drugs and and prazone
doctors said we don't need to know about
that nutrition stuff people get sick we
give them some Wonder drugs and cure
them US Senate document
264 now this one here you should pay
attention to this is kind of an overlay
map of the continental United States and
this shows you how much selenium is in
the soil in various areas or regions of
the country the black areas have
absolutely no selenium in it the dark
gray areas probably don't it's kind of a
maybe maybe not so if you eat food out
of your own garden or you go to a
farmers market and get very fresh fruits
and vegetables or grains and whatnot I
still do on it from the field in Idaho
are you getting any selenium no Farmers
know they better give selenium to their
sheep and their horses and their pigs
and cows otherwise you get white muscle
disease or stiff lamb disease or mulbury
heart disease why do we do that for our
livestock and we don't take care of
ourselves
okay just a quick detailed look at two
minerals and we'll wind it up and open
it up for questions uh let's look at
calcium everybody knows about calcium
since tum started talking about
osteoporosis osteoporosis of course is a
tragic disease it's the number 10 killer
of adults in the United States is very
costly in terms of human misery and
dollars it cost $35,000 to have each hip
replaced if you get them both replaced
they're in fact um uh $70,000
Now farmers know that we can prevent
osteoporosis and animals and we don't
have osteoprosis and animals even
because or even though we have such a
terrible time with it in humans and
here's why farmers are very practical
let's say you have a 100 head of cows
out in the pasture and you didn't have
any calvs this year can't repay your
operating loan you call the vet out and
you say man do I get rid of this her of
cows it cost me a lot of money this year
feed and labor and maintain in the fence
and pasture and I didn't get any calves
what's happening here so the vet
examines the cows he says no there's
nothing wrong with the cows here but
your bull over there has osteoporosis of
both his hips had so much pain couldn't
breed the cows that's why he didn't have
any calves he said I tell you what you
give me $70,000 I'll give that bull two
new hips and next year you'll have some
calves so a farmer being a practical guy
says stand over here doc boom blows a
bull away 28 cents and well the uh uh
kids are grinding them up into hamburger
and cutting steaks and roast off that
old bull the farmer says now Doc for
$70,000 I can get a new bull every year
for 70 years you know I wasn't going to
spend that kind of money uh but every
once in a while I get one I'd like to
keep because he throws good calves any
way I can prevent that OA prois thing
and the vet says well sure um every time
you wean one of those bull Cavs just
give them 10 cents a day worth of
calcium in his pellets and the farmer
says you mean I can prevent a $70,000
vet bill simply by giving 10 cents a day
worth of calcium and the pels he says
well yeah he says well I'm going to do
that because I don't have insurance for
those animals because I have to pay for
it out of my own pocket I'm going to do
the 10cent a day thing that's why we
don't have osteoporosis and animals now
receding gums is another one dentists
will tell you to floss and brush after
every meal if you want to avoid or cure
receding gums if you believe that really
works I have some ocean front property
in Idaho to sell
you because it doesn't work I've seen
hundreds of thousands of animals rats
rabbits mice ra uh dogs cats sheep
horses pigs cows lions and tigers and
bears and they don't floss and they
don't get receding gums and they do get
funky
breath now the reason why we don't get
receding gums in animals is because
we've taken care of the osteoporosis
problem gingivitis receding gums loose
teeth uh periodontitis pyara Bridges
plates all of these different diseases
really are just osteoporosis of the
facial bones and the jaw bones and
that's why we don't have these problems
in animals because we've taken care of
the osteoporosis problem if you have any
of those dental problems you in fact
have osteoporosis of the face or jaw
bones arthritis now get your pencils out
because I'm going to give you that
complete arthritis formula at this point
for those of you who stayed tonight and
been a great audience um Dr Wallock Pig
arthritis formula goes like this 5
ounces of calcium enriched mint made
orange juice 5 ounces of calcium
enriched mint made orange juice 2/4 ounz
packets of nox gelatin unflavored and
unsweetened 1 ounz of mineral TT for the
colloidal minerals including colloidal
calcium and magnesium and Boron and 1
ounce of total ttty are Ultra body ttty
this will give you the basic Dr Wallock
Pig arthritis
formula take that twice a day Faithfully
for two months and then call me in the
morning I'll say it one more time 5
ounces of calcium enrich minute made
orange
juice two4 oun envelopes of nox gelatin
unflavored and unsweetened 1 o of
mineral ttty and 1 ounce of either total
tat or Ultra body taty which are
vitamins amino acids and min mineral
that mixture 7 and2 ounces you want to
take twice a day Faithfully for 2 months
before you decide whether it's actually
helping your arthritis or not
hypertension high blood pressure is not
due to too much salt in your diet it
won't help you if you take salt out of
your diet what's the first thing that a
good husbandman puts out for his
livestock is about that big a salt block
and a dumb old cow can have all she
wants now doctors think people are
dumber than cows cow can have all the
salt she wants but you can't have any
right well we learned um 5 years ago
from a study that was was paid for with
your tax money $30 million they studied
high blood pressure they took 10,000
people 5,000 of which had high blood
pressure they took them off of all salt
medications to see if just a salt-free
diet would help people live longer and
of course they all died very quickly
can't live without salt then they took
5,000 people in a control group they let
them salt their food in fact encourag
them to Salt their food to taste and
then they made them take three times the
RDA of calcium they don't even know why
they did that they just wanted to do
something different in the control group
have nothing to do with salt and that
control group is supposed to run 20
years to compare with the other group
that already died out well they had to
stop the control group in 6 weeks
because 85% of them were cured of their
high blood pressure just simply by
tripling your calcium intake how many of
you got that notice from your doctor
saying it's okay to Salt your food to
taste but please please do double or
triple your intake of calcium especially
if you have high blood pressure not a
single person in this room okay insomnia
as where you roll around all night wake
up in the morning more tired when you
went to bed that's not a barbituate
deficiency it's a Calcium deficiency
okay your doctor likes to give you
barbituates kill about 10,000 people a
year but that's okay as prescription so
they keep track of the numbers for
you they have a new one out called hon
doesn't kill you but it has terrible
side effects of stomach cramping nausea
vomiting and that's what they gave
George Bush when he went to Japan uh to
sleep on Air Force One you know he's
going he was going to negotiate with the
car trade ambassadors there from Japan
and when I came home I always turn on
CNN news and I turned that on and here's
these Japanese news casers I thought the
whole Japanese economy had collapsed I
mean these guys were taking their ties
off and throwing their jackets on the
desk and their hair was all over the
place sweat flying around they're saying
things like oh how gas konichiwa
Bush and then I saw that news thing with
him puking all over them guys I mean he
could blame his doctor's prescription
for losing the the presidency because
that wasn't very
[Music]
presidential then there's kidney stones
bone spurs heel spurs and calcium
deposits doctors have the malignant dumb
belief that you have too much calcium in
your diet when you get those things and
they say absolutely no Dairy and for
God's sake don't take any supplements
with calcium in it when in reality you
only get calcium kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
when you have a raging osteoporosis in
reality you need more calcium and more
magnesium not
less couple more here cramps and
Twitches how many of you ever had a foot
cramp raise your hand be honest just
about everybody in the room has been
awakened with a foot cramp right that's
a Calcium deficiency your body's
screaming at you give me some calcium
darn it then of course there's Twitches
eyelid Twitches muscle twitches be
honest how many of you ever had an
eyelid twitch raise your hand yeah just
about everybody in the room now when I
was 14 years old my eyelid used to
Twitch so loud you could hear them and
it sounded like and I'd look in the
mirror and say to people see that is
that my imagination I look sure enough I
could I caught it one day and I called
my mom hey mom look at this and she
didn't know what it was so we jumped in
the car and we drove 80 miles to St
Louis we went to this lady eye doctor
I'll never forget her name was Mary Jane
skevington and for some reason she had
me strip down to my Jockey underwear I
mean she was an eye
doctor I mean today I get on Oprah with
sexual harassment right but back then it
was just kind of a curiosity and what
what's her interest here you know I mean
I was 14 years old so any rate she'd
look in my eyes and U kind of shred her
shoulder she go look at another patient
she come back and look in my eyes and
and after about an hour that I said you
know doc look I play on the junior
varsity football team I'm the captain of
the wrestling team I'm on the
weightlifting team if you have to amput
my eyelids to go for it I mean I can do
whatever is necessary I can't stand this
twitching and cramping in my eyes and so
she knew I was frustrated she goes to
her office she comes back with a little
Maybelline mascara eyelash brush and a
little mirror I said now what's all that
far she says well your eyes appear to be
normal but you do have long eyelashes
and I think they've hit your glasses
curled back and you're tickling your
eyeballs and that's what's
happening and I said yeah and she says
and she starts demonstrating says what I
want you to do is every hour alternate
eyes and start actually retraining your
eyelashes as no wait a minute you want
me to sit on the football bench with 25
guys weighing over 200 lb and you want
me to start playing with my eyelash I
mean these guys will sharpen their
cleats and kill me my own team will kill
me so I put on my pants and I go
marching off to the school library and I
look at a health book written by a
couple of nurses and I look in the index
and their muscle cramps muscle twitches
and sure enough it says Calcium
deficiency now I'm 14 years old the only
place I knew we had calcium was in those
calf pellets in the barn so I ran to the
barn and I had to make this decision was
I going to do this Maybelline mascara
eyelash treatment or was I going to eat
calf p
so I started eating calf
pellets everybody else in school is
popping M&M's you know and I'm eating
calf
pellets so in three days time all those
cramps and Twitches went away and of
course I knew then the doctors didn't
know anything about anatomy and probably
I didn't know what the connection was
between the eyes and the other parts and
then they didn't know anything about
nutrition now PMS premenstrual syndrome
the University of California 6 years ago
came out and said that 85% of the the
physical and emotional stuff of PMS
could in fact be reversed prevented and
cured simply by tripling your intake of
calcium over and above the RDA of
calcium so guys if you have a gal in
your family a mother a sister a wife a
daughter or maybe a boss or coworker
don't give them flowers and chocolate to
try and calm them down give them some
calcium and everybody will be happier
now low back pain 85% of all back pain
is due to either osteoporosis or the
vertebrae regardless of your age even if
you're 10 years old if you have low back
pain you can have osteoporosis of the
vertebrae or
uh cramps and spasms in the muscles and
so you want to use Dr Wall's Pig
arthritis formula for all of these
things now it's the criminal thing about
this
is these are just the top 10 out of 147
different diseases that can be caused by
a Calcium deficiency just 10 because we
have good insurance and because we have
Medicare and Medicaid the average person
in America will spend somewhere between
25,000 and
$250,000 during their lifetime and
undergo 5 to 10 surgical procedures for
nothing more than a Calcium deficiency
any other industry where you can do
something for 10 cents and they charge
you $250,000 they get put in jail for
fraud but in medicine we just ask the
doctor or the government to tax us so we
can pay
them I find that
fascinating last one diabetes number
three killers of Americans causes
blindness of all kinds kidney failure
requiring dialysis or maybe kidney
transplant cardiovasular disease of all
kinds amputations of toes feet and legs
and if you really are determined to get
an amputation make sure you tag the
right leg you know to make sure the
doctor gets the right one and uh this is
really criminal because every time your
doctor um diagnosed as a new diabetic in
his his um office he drops to his knees
and gives thanks to the Lord and then
when he gets up he runs over and picks
up the telephone calls his real estate
agent says hey I need a new apartment
complex or a strip mall or a farm I need
to dump $250,000 to $500,000 because I
got a new diabetic patient it's kind of
like adding a new dairy cow to the herd
you know how much money you're going to
get during the the useful life of that
cow now 1957 we learned in animals that
we could prevent and cure diabetes with
two trace minerals anal onside onset
diabetes chromium and vadium would
prevent and cure it 10 years ago 1985
the medical school at the University of
Vancouver British Columbia Canada came
out and said the trace mineral vadium
alone could replace insulin for adult
onset diabetics